you um
you've also mentioned to me offline that
you're really excited about all the
different
wearables and all the different ways we
can collect
information about our bodies about uh
well the whole thing is what's most
exciting to you
in terms of collecting the the
biological
uh data about a human being
well so i'm a biologist i find animals
and humans
as machines very interesting it's one of
the reasons i didn't become
an engineer or a surgeon i wanted to
understand how we actually are built
and so i think a lot about machines
merging with humans and the first of
that are the bio wearables
and so i talked a lot about this i wrote
about it in life span the book and
pictured a future where you would be
monitored constantly
so that you wouldn't suddenly have a
heart attack you'd know that was coming
or you you wouldn't go to the doctor and
they don't know if it's you need an
antibiotic or not um
long term how old are you how to fix
things what should you eat what should
you take what should you
do these devices i predicted would be
smarter
better educated than you than your
physician and would augment them
and then there'd be a human that would
just tick off to see if that it's
correct and they approve
i also was predicting in the book that
we would have video conferences with our
doctors and that medicines would be
delivered
initially by courier but eventually by
drones and get it to you sometimes in an
emergency
and that we could even have pills that
were synthesized or delivered
in your kitchen and combined certainly
what's amazing about that is that what
are we now
two years since the book came out even
less
and that future is basically here
already covered
uh 19 accelerates accelerated that
incredibly
so where we're at now in society is if
you if you want to pay for it you can
have a blood test that will detect
cancer
10 20 years earlier than it would before
it forms a tumor
you can of course do your genome very
cheaply for less than 100
now there are bio wearables already i
wear
this ring from aura that i have number
of years of data
i've been doing blood tests for the last
12 years with a company called inside
tracker which
i consult for and so i have all of that
data as well and there's
34 different parameters on my
testosterone my blood glucose my
inflammation and i use all that data to
of course i wear a watch that that
measures things as well i use that data
to keep my body in optimal shape so i'm
now 51
and according to those parameters i'm at
least as good as someone in their early
40s
and i if i really work at it i can get
my biochemistry down to
early to mid 30s though i like to you
know now
eat a little dessert once in a while
so that's the future we're in right now
anyone can do what i just said
but in the very near future just in the
next few years
you can be wearing wearables so i'm
currently wearing a little
what's called a bio sticker uh this one
um i just put on last night uh it's
about
an inch long a few millimeters yeah for
people just listening it's uh
san diego's chest yeah it's just how
does it attach it's just kind of
it sticks on yeah so on one side you
have an on button that you press
the lights come on flashes four times
it's good to go it
immediately syncs to your phone and
this one uh the it's called a biobutton
nice name and there's a there's another
one that i have that i haven't tried yet
that does ekg on your heart um this is
mainly for doctors to monitor patients
that go home after a heart attack or
surgery
but that's medical grade fda approved
device
so there will be a day in fact it's
already here that
doctors are using these to get patients
to go home and save
a week in hospital two thousand dollars
at least for each patient
that's massive safe savings for the
hospital
but ultimately what i'm excited about is
a future that isn't that far off where
everybody certainly in developed
countries eventually these will cost a
few cents and rechargeable
the only cost will be the software
subscription that can be monitored
constantly
and to give an idea what this is
measuring me at a thousand times a
second
is uh my vibrations as i speak
my orientation it can already has told
me this morning how i slept
where i slept what side i slept on
we've got sneezing coughing body
temperature
heart rate heart of other parameters of
the heart
that would indicate heart health these
these data are being used to now
to predict sickness so
eventually we'll have just in the next
year or so the ability to predict
whether something or diagnose whether
something is pneumonia
or just a rhinovirus that can be treated
or not
right this is really going to not just
revolutionize medicine but i think
extend lives dramatically
because if i have if i'm going to have a
heart attack next week and that's
possible
this device should know that and i'll be
in hospital before i even have it
maybe you can talk a little bit about
inside tracker because i saw that
there's some really cool things in there
like it
actually so maybe you can talk about i
guess that you're collecting blood
to give it the data so and it has like
basic recommendations on how to improve
your life
so we're not just talking about diseases
right like anticipating
having a particular disease but it's
almost like guiding your trajectory to
life how to
whether it's extend your your life or
just
live a more fulfilling like improve the
quality of life i suppose this is the
right way to say it
what how does inside tracker work uh
what the heck is it because i thought
there was also pretty cool
yeah what is it i guess it's something
other people can use
you can definitely use it uh you can
sign up it's consumer
it's like a company consumer facebook
company it is yeah
cool uh and i also want to democratize
the ability to
to just take a mouth swab eventually we
don't need to have a blood test
necessarily
but for now it's a blood test and and
you'd go to a lab core request in the us
it's also available overseas you can
upload your own data
for a minimal cost and get the
algorithms the ai
in the background to take that data plot
where you are against others in your age
group as in terms of health and
longevity by your age they call it inner
age but also
it provides recommendations and this
isn't just a bunch of bs it sounds like
it might be
to say i'll go eat this or go to that
restaurant and order that but it's
actually based on
they basically this company has entered
hundreds
now it would be thousands of scientific
papers into their database
and hundreds of thousands of human data
points and they have
tens of thousands of individuals that
have been tracked over time
and anonymously that data is used to say
what works and what doesn't
if you eat that what works if you take
that supplement what works
and i was a co-author on a paper that
showed that the recommendations for
food and supplements
was better than the leading drug for
type 2 diabetes
that's so cool the idea that you can
connect like skipping
the human having to do this work you can
connect the scientific papers
almost like meta-analysis of the science
connected to the individual data
and then based on that sort of connect
your data to
whatever the proper group is within the
whatever the scientific paper is
to make the suggestion of how how like
how that work
applies to your life and then that
ultimately maps to like a recommendation
what you should do with your life
like it all like this giant system
that ultimately recommends you should
drink more coffee or less
right and and we'll have the genome in
there as well you can upload that yeah
uh and so so these programs will know us
way better than
we do and and our doctors as well the
idea of going to a doctor once a year
for an
annual checkup and having you know males
get a finger up their butt and uh
you know you cough that that to me is a
joke that's medieval
uh medicine and that's very soon going
to be seen as medieval
yeah it's um to me as a computer science
person
it's always upsetting to go to the
doctor and just
look at him and like realize you know
nothing about me
like you you're you're you're making
your like opinions
based on like it is very valuable
years of intuition building about basic
symptoms but you're just like it is
medieval
they're very good at it in fact doctors
in medieval times are probably damn good
at working with very little but the
thing is
you i'd rather pref for a doctor that
doesn't really know what they're doing
but has a huge amount of data to work
with
well you're right and many of my good
friends are doctors i work at harvard um
so i'm not
against the profession at all yeah but i
think that they need just as much help
as anyone else does
we wouldn't drive a car without a
dashboard we wouldn't think of it so why
would doctors do the same
you